Tây thầy nào bột công nước, giật lộ phòng.
Bây giờ thầy bò những cuộc nước đã.
Như vậy bao giờ phương miệt kế này của anh nào.
Nước đã, mà thầy của anh nào đã.
Bây giờ thầy bò những cuộc nước đã này.
Và trong cuộc nước.
Đó.
Thế đi, kế em à, chắc chắn một điều tí nữa.
Sau một khoảng thời gian, thì cái công nước đã này.
Nó sẽ giật lộ xuống, tắc cảm giác nước.
Và ta cần thể nó mắt lại.
Bông anh thầy giải thích, thích chiều truyền nghiệt, nó rất nước.
Và nước đã, khi hay bật có nhỉ tổ tháng nhạc,
thì sẽ có sự truyền nghiệt, nó tự vật có nhỉ tổ cào,
sang bật có nhỉ tổ thơ vật.
Nhớ nhỉ tự vật có nhỉ tổ cào, sang bật có nhỉ tổ thơ vật.
Thế đi, kì bò.
Những cuộc nước đã vào công lực.
Thế nước này, giật năng tự nước.
Sẽ chuyển cho nước đã.
Những nước đã, giật năng,
nước này, nước đã, pán trải.
Con đổ bi nước, thì nó mắt giật năng đi.
Khi phần giật năng của cái nước trong cuộc bị mắt đi.
Zó chuyển sang cho nước đã, tỉ tổ gọi nó đã giật năng.
Những này, giật năng của cuộc nước.
Sẽ ra hảm sốt.
Nhìn năng mất đi, thì nhìn nó, sẽ ra hảm sốt.
Đấy, bây giờ, cho này, thầy lũi lần.
Có hà sự nhầm lần.
Chuyển lần thứ nhất?
Các em nhìn tự vận, ở đây có sự chuyển nghiệt lọc không phải.
Ờ đây, giữa nước vận, đã có sự chuyển nghiệt,
năng, giữa nước vận, kái sai và gái yên thứ hai.
Nó kéo tưởng là gì?
Nước đã chuyển hơi lại sang cho nước.
Nhưng không phải.
Không phải.
Zó, giữa năng của nước trong cuộc, lưới năng như năng của nước đã.
Chó nên giữa năng chuyển từ nước sang nước đã.
Chúng không phải chứ vực lại.
Tạm miệt, tất cả kẻ em phải, hảm sốt lại.
Yến bây giờ, bây giờ.
Cái thầy lần.